today I show an iron fist it man the II
saw some iron fist I finally saw some
iron fist together we're gonna iron fist
it make a hole make a big old big old
for me big ol arm this Ben yeah
I'm ribbing it for your pleasure tonight
about like this
today I'm brand-new fat man on that
[Music]
welcome to that matter I'm Batman I'm
Kevin Smith
I am knocking on that's right we're
gonna go to kun LUN mother yes well
kinda sorta yeah little buddy she could
have could have been flashback the Lisa
Ryan mark
has he broken about iron fist marbles
iron fist has debuted on Netflix
yes worth of them this looks Marvel
shows that were was and we having that
huge [ __ ] fans of everything that
Marvel is done to the point we're often
accused publicly on Twitter of how much
they paying you to start their [ __ ]
dick nothing there ditched tasty [ __ ]
and if your taste is good I'd suck it
for free too
this little kit sprinkling like vanilla
on your dick now so good yes gonna
cinnamon sugar so taste it's like a
churro oh that is that this is the first
time I guess it seemed like before I one
watch the episode I'm not influenced by
public opinions but I got a lot of
opinion on the internet if people go on
wha-wha lot of people's on what happened
then the bull or the pepper Vegas fallen
and a lot of complaints and stuff like
that but we all know me mark y bar is
very low you you are a positive person
oh you like to like things which is
totally great because who wants to live
in a world where you don't want to like
think bang and not even kids I'm like
I'm pigs with money a better like it
[ __ ] Netflix I think I get it for
free not sure I don't know how we get it
some store and go a little exactly I put
a credit card numbers down years ago I'm
sure it's pretty much down it's just
like my oh well I still think so very
well you pay very well yeah you get a
monthly [ __ ] thing in the day but you
know what I believe in them never doing
anyway that's all for today
mm a CD that you had to put into living
loaded everything other than that I'll
have you know in Hollywood still used
may well I know I was I was shocked by
how many show winners that I would
encounter I feel as though rocks today
well you know Damon Lindelof used to
have one until not too long ago he
traded up he traded up to high all kinds
of trading up it okay okay enough of the
free commercial for Hale Welch because
they meet all of our money they could
you though the we were all on all in for
this [ __ ] I love this [ __ ]
so my bar is very very low so you know
because I've seen people be like who
gives a [ __ ] you love everything great
so watch something out go watch the
hater channel where they're like a fool
configured really like you said we go
and wanna [ __ ] love it man because
guess what when we were kids there was
no Iron Fist [ __ ] show to [ __ ] about
you couldn't sit there and be like it's
not as good as the one I made in my
imagination because people were like
Iron Fist the [ __ ] is that
comic books what the [ __ ] are those get
rocked in your [ __ ] face on TV me TBD
we like that [ __ ] in any event target
you know number one bigger point out
aren't no memorable theme song that's
not even close I couldn't even come
close to doing this oh wow
point band I'm generally fairly generous
to things take it take it all the grin
saw you already went forward yes I am
slightly more critical in yeah yeah in
general but like I still want to like a
thing yeah because life is too short to
not want to like stuff that's true but I
came to iron fist and I didn't like it
you struck the stumbled
I stumbled yes the sisters not as iron
as I was hoping it would be how these
did you get when you know when I talked
about it I got the first fix in okay
since I've seen mer six over six things
and get the full sir no since I've seen
five more some eleven deep now you made
it to eleven it I made it to eleven
episodes which I mean as a you guys it's
ain't easy you got to want it this is
this is not like TV for amateurs you
can't just coast your way to the finish
line you've got a [ __ ] gut through
some [ __ ] there I'm on Episode three
yeah and look is it horrible is it
horrible not by any stretch of
imagination is the daredevil not by any
stretch of the imagination here's what
I've been I've been trying to think
about like what what's the problem
because I liked it they hit the ground
running episode 1 like you know BAM
there is walking in Iran enterprises and
also he's got to [ __ ] do some [ __ ]
but I was like what is it how come why
is it like you know it's like you know
who that's not it
oh that's not hey that's my ass hey like
it's just taking a little while to find
purchase if you will but here's my
theory daredevil you know the excitement
of like holy [ __ ] they're gonna do ten
twelve episodes of daredevil is the
first time we've seen daredevil since
then act like oh my god and then you
know you get them [ __ ] Charlie Cox is
amazing and then you know and then that
second episode shows you that amazing
hallway fight and then wait a minute
Wilson Fisk comes in and [ __ ] steals
the show for a while so they had their
first season there was the odd like oh
my god the newness and also it was
impeccable
one of the best first seasons of this
show one of the best seasons of a
television show ever but when you look
at like Jessica Jones Jessica Jones also
had Luke Cage to lean on and you know
they were kind of Co introduced on her
show right so Luke Cage you had a kind
of like by the time they started his
show you look like know him
is on Jessica's job Danny ran starting
cold son there's no like oh I loved him
in this episode and Colleen Winstar cold
of them like you know okay you see a
little bit you get in a little phone
number or something like that so I felt
maybe that might be a problem for some
cats maybe that's what some cats
responding to there's no like alright
there's something comfy with them he's a
friend or a because we saw in the
previous episode this is the first of
the Marvel series on Netflix
that's not bearable where the character
and all the characters are coming in
cold I'm at the filter is still dancing
Claire temple yet yeah you're not gonna
get that to like six or seven I think
wait for roadog looking to make you wait
look I'll wait forever photographers era
Dawson but I was kind of hoping you know
based at the pace for going they'd get
her in a lot sooner
wait you're not excited about Danny ran
claiming that he's Danny ran to
everybody he meets there who don't
believe him despite the fact that we
know he's Danny ran in the show says
he's Danny ran put any believes did he
say any rants but here's the thing this
is where I will let it go because I'm
like you keep saying joining ran you
know that's a low mark where I'm just
like right on I know who Danny Rand is
he's the iron fist and he's like I get
excited they say even though they said
it ten thousand times he's the one
usually [ __ ] saying it I get excited
by every Danny Rand scene even though he
seems very thin you know I'm not Assizes
but and maybe this sounds kind of like
it was coming from [ __ ] I'd [ __ ] eat
a sandwich to this kid really said but
whatever he don't need dirt he needs to
summon his Chi and [ __ ] focus it into
the power of the iron fist so he don't
have to be [ __ ] super strong it's the
Michael it's the Michael Keaton Batsuit
phenomena you know what I'm saying as
long he's got the iron fist he could be
scrubbing I'm okay every time he's
talked about I'm Danny ran seems like
we've spent a long time in hospital hole
up sewed with him drugged up music and I
was trying to be like come on he can't
[ __ ] like do that I was body but no
he's a like 15 years
though he crashes in the Himalayans or a
dimension hidden within an Emily and
he's never had to deal with [ __ ]
drugs or anything so you know the body
it can only do so much
I'll buy that mmm but [ __ ] you'd like
we're spending a lot of time with them
with you family the bad fans the
meetings you're not excited about what
all join would meet you okay and they're
like I'm three episodes in I'm like dad
away I can't see the story you and your
[ __ ] brother and your dead dad are in
the way he's dead right well nobody's
room for real alive just people think
he's dead
living in penthouse in my spoiler if you
hadn't watched it spoiler if you never
buddy is dead no but he's not dead
people think he's dead like Danny Rand
but he was not resurrected by the hand
or something not as they portray it why
is it so scared of the hand i onions
like that's why he wants to Danny to go
like use Danny go after a to be so piece
that seems to man it's like you drugged
up your hero and it just seemed like I'm
look I'm not a I'm not a I'm not a good
writer
but let's just put down the table I
wrote yo goes is there [ __ ] you can
dismiss anything I say after you but I
just like you know I don't know that
there was a lot of expository
information with like Danny it's me like
not me babble exposition let me explain
[ __ ] to you and everybody and let me get
some Mattia but again that's these are
that's bad for me was a small quibble
because at least it was like forward
momentum but too much time with the
family so for me and you know but I'm in
still I'm not I'm not jumping [ __ ] like
nothing I I'm not all in for the
defenders so this is the road that it
takes this is data like I do when do her
so far I mean you know I'm not that deep
but Colleen wing is enjoyable she's
pretty badass and I and I don't have as
much a problem with Finn Joe
as other people have but I'll be honest
with you like now I can't help but see
the version of like why don't they go
with an Asian American like you know
even if it was like well my mother you
know and my father is a white guy or
whatever split it up but like he could
have been buckaroo banzai it's you know
and there's no complaint against Ben
Jones I think he's totally fine in that
really think their moment so I'm like
why not but it seemed like you were so
close why not just yeah and you know
stories have come out that they did
interview an Asian actor at some point
for the lead and then decided to cast
him as a sort of baby boss villain
gun in Lewiston yeah I just saw that on
the internet yeah here's what it's so
like eight or something like seven or
eight I think yeah and then a bunch of
people were like he's like why not I got
yeah I mean my problem I was a Mia so I
can't live I mean my problem you know I
did it in much broader cannabis but I
don't know a what Danny Rand wants other
than boys by episode 11 you it's still
unclear like he knows the [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] serious because I'm so threes
going like complicate them well five
Episode six they generally uncomplicated
say yeah they have an uncomplicated by
about 11 like his his what starts off if
I want to be the head of rain
corporation for reasons that are unclear
and never made clear then it is I have
to destroy the hand because apparently
they're nested nested inside the ran
cooperation which is great then it's I
gotta get Madame Gao off the table
because why I don't know possibly she
has information about who killed his
parents for real if they were actually
dead unclear and more I don't know what
the show is about hmm you know like you
go into daredevil you understand what
that shows about that shows about
justice and injustice you get Jessica
Jones is show about PTSD and survivors
Luke Cage the show about power in the
face of powerlessness about being strong
you're not able to affect change this is
a show about I don't know you know and
I'm 11 episodes deep and if I don't know
what a show is about 11 episodes
then that somewhat troubling by episode
11
is there anything close to they don't do
the costume do it there are flashbacks
to cream in Finland where he's wearing
colors but does he ever wear a headpiece
no and you tell me if I've sewed 11 they
still make that dress appear no there is
there is like you know footage harvested
from like the 40s of the previous Iron
Fist who is like in the dead know that's
it basically like all black headpiece
and he's got two flaming iron fists not
just the one because he's good at it but
that's about it but it doesn't look like
the [ __ ] yeah the dollar
there's no [ __ ] collar there's no TV
there's no there's no gold LeMay
anywhere and I'm not saying if they
don't do that they're [ __ ] but it's
like come on and I mean he's got like
you like Luke Cage found a way to at
least references for like there it is he
says he looks like an [ __ ] but we buy
it but he's got the crown and yes yellow
and we all felt the same way it as well
thank God they did hear that word but I
don't know this dude in a world where
it's like what's your power
how are the iron fist like you know I'm
a living weapon I focus on my TV right
into my [ __ ] you get away with that
outfit with that declaration of purpose
you get away you know and like the other
problem that I had and it's it's
manifesting one and worse is all the way
through the martial arts is not good and
well look I'll you know it's better than
anything I could do
then shoot I'll say that as well that
being said this is the first time you
know me like his weird they have a
filmmaker but I don't really notice the
facade but this is the first of the
series where I'm like oh these fight
episodes are very Cudi yeah
whereas daredevil was like one long they
made a point of when you were like that
boom that's as real as raincoat yeah
we're hiding the cut so that you feel
seamless we're here there was a clip
they went around fine I'm not really see
the problem is like part of the day it's
like that's what they do in TV movie
an even in daredevil they they they're
able to hide a stunt guy like he's got a
mascot and for sure but like we live in
a world in which you get stuff like into
the Badlands on AMC which is a martial
arts show yeah spends the time they
train there they may make it look like I
make it look at they put these guys in
camp for four or five months and train
them on how to be movie martial arts you
get stuff like John wick which yes is a
movie but a movie shot on the cheap
you get [ __ ] daredevil where they
took the time like if there weren't
other comparisons that worked then this
would not feel as as sort of offensive
it feels to me like this is the fourth
planet the Apes movie Oh No
well it's like oh we spent the money big
here a little bit more than big here but
now we're in the ones in the back row
can just have rubber man yeah like we
don't have to go full makeup with we
time-traveled to contemporary Los
Angeles right so we don't have to build
sets so we don't have to like we got two
people to make up and everybody else's
human so what are you chose you're
saying it's conquest
no escape from escape if it's good move
it's good movie but they spent no money
on that movie so is Iron Fist escape
good no it's escape budgeting it's like
you're just well no but yeah like
there's just like I get it from a
production perspective to like listen we
spent a fortune on daredevil and we went
hard and we trained Charlie Cox and we
did we have the stunt team we we gave
you that now it's come on [ __ ]
episode of Magnum like Magnum or
something look like a [ __ ] ninja this
looks like Magnum sometimes right but
there's there's a three the Magnum the
magnet Magnum this there's a there's a
clip is revolving online which the
30-second clip fight scene from it from
the show and it's got 56 cuts in it oh
and they are just like this is a cycle
bag cut but yeah there's this other
great thing where it's a scene of Liam
Neeson climbing a fence and taken I'm
keen as you know it's a size 14 extorted
cut to get to bat to get
50 year-old man over a fence it's a bit
like that we're like you know you just
can't show me Finn Jones because he
didn't do it and he interviews but it's
all one wide shot though in the opening
episode where he again my bars low where
he you know did the where they call when
he so I can make themselves an L took
the foot out oh yeah and he pressed the
elevator button was like I can't be the
berry good impressive to me that was
impressive but he did this interview I
can't member with who I think was a
Guardian in the UK and said that he had
three weeks to train before they shot
three weeks and then there were some
fight scenes where he learned the
choreography 15 minutes before they shot
it I mean look this is not I mean that's
the speed with which in the rate at
which we make super girl and you know
the spikes they know they're fun
coordinator because they've been working
with them for like years
a year now on that show particularly and
the five team is amazing very cinematic
but because like they do 23 episodes I
think a season like they're going very
fast right so all the stuff is built out
by the stunt team son team presents it
to the director or whoever's in charge
you're like this is great you shoot the
stunt people why'd you shoot clothes
shoot their backs whatever [ __ ] and then
you pop in your bleed and like Melissa
they'll teach Melissa a routine as a
routine lab so where she had to fight
like a [ __ ] bunch of palace guards at
once and you know they were they worked
with her they worked it all out and then
they had Melissa on the day for
literally 10 minutes for a shot
it was just like they just do it in beat
so you know it's nice to be like
mystified by the [ __ ] never try to
include stunts or action because I'm
like who can do this
you leave it up to pros I'll show you
how to do it man so they'll do three
beats with her so it's just like okay
Melissa's last and then you weave back
and then kick and elbow so this we bob
this and elbow and they'll just shoot
that until like Oh perfect and then
they'll do the next three beats of the
five seems like that's that's what he's
describing is that if he's learning the
routine right 15 minutes before looking
shoes like that you're getting they
doing a view show and that's not being
dismissive I'm just saying that's how
fast they're going
but I don't need to go that fast they
don't need to go that fast
Supergirl has the benefit of we've been
doing this for three years but the stunt
team is trained up in Melissa's trained
up two years and Melissa Supergirl is
not supposed to be the living weapon
that is the iron fist yes like once you
once you lay claim to like it's as if
Michael B Jordan doesn't have to be as
good a boxer as Apollo Creed no he's got
to be yeah and he was convincing okay
totally like he did the work he puts in
the time and he D nails it so you can do
that that sequence and iMovie the first
round that he fight here when it's Sigma
in Iran then he goes and yeah but no
it's afraid it's the first uh it's a
true professional fight and the first
round doesn't have a cut it's a
three-minute shot and you can do that
because you train up a guy you put him
in the wings you work out the
choreography he memorizes it he
practises it and they were done ever
weeks yeah like that's what it takes it
takes time and the minor feature you got
that but again well you know it's a
series but the series is Iron Fist it's
all about later good it's telling me on
that and they've already shown us that
they could do this if we didn't see it
in daredevil nobody would have thought
it possible but they could do it in
daredevil so they should have been able
to do it here and that they did is the
problem it doesn't make me dislike Iron
Fist as much as it makes me appreciate
their double more see that man that's a
beautiful they call me feed upon like it
all alright job as I devour more of
these episodes and you're getting to the
end we'll do another check-in will iron
will take the iron fist a bit deeper
yeah and then week there's a move the
story move that they make in episode
eleven I think that is the smartest
thing they've done on the show my guy I
was actually hope you know what [ __ ]
nice job iron fist like did not see that
coming
totally change the tenor of the show
well done you guys so I don't I'm not
hating it to hate it but there is this
really smart interesting story move did
they make I'm getting there and I will
give me a reason it involves the hand I
won't spoil any more than that really
the hand is in the show I'm sorry Oh
Willie Mays you saw the hand on the
window oh my gosh what's slow playing
everything else including boardroom
meetings like do I need more boardroom
meeting a few of those yeah Anna knows
that but in any event there it is iron
fist
more to come on that in the coming weeks
until then man we'll be talking about
their [ __ ] come back next episode we'll
talk about the [ __ ] man so now that's it
fat man Batman I'm Kevin Spacey marking
our comeback next up so same bat-time
same bat-channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
you
[Music]